[Music]
hey everyone its Johanna here this is a
requested video on understanding what to
eat before and after your workout
session pre and post-workout meals and
meals which you eat right before and
right after working out these meals are
crucial and can help to improve your
performance and results for instance to
burn fat and to gain muscles to increase
strength and to be healthier so what you
eat before your workout acts as fill or
energy to maximize performance during
your workout session what you eat after
is important to optimize muscle recovery
which basically begins as soon as your
rakal ends never ever work out on an
empty stomach working out on an empty
stomach is like trying to drive a car
without gas Eureka will suffer because
you will not have enough energy to
sustain it or you will be too distracted
by hunger to keep focus so let's start
by understanding pre-workout snacks
pre-workout snacks are also known as
energy base because they play the
largest role in providing your body with
maximum energy in order for you to
workout at your 100% effort in order for
this to happens we want to feel our body
with meals which are heavier on cups and
a little bit of protein because cars is
the best source of energy and they
digest easily the pre-workout snacks
which I will be sharing with you are
light small and easy to digest and this
is suitable to be consumed 30 to 60
minutes before your workout if you are
planning to have a bigger and heavier
meal have a balanced meal of carbs
healthy fats and protein for at least
three hours before working out so here
are some examples of pre-workout snacks
whole-wheat toast with peanut butter and
banana whole-wheat toast will provide
you with complex carbs which are
especially important for workout
endurance and
are also a great source of carbs and
they are perfect for raising potassium
level which tend to drop when you sweat
a lot as for peanut butter it is high in
protein and it digests easily the next
snack is Greek yogurt with fruits what I
have here are frozen berries yogurt
provides you with cups and protein to
keep you energized and the added fruits
contain natural sugar for the extra
energy boost and feel free to change it
for another fruits of your choice do you
want something refreshing and life event
try this high-protein fruit smoothie
blend 1 cup of frozen berries or your
favorite fruit with one cup of water and
one scoop of your favorite protein
powder having a liquid base snack prior
to your workout will make it easy for
your body to digest and the water
content will keep your body hydrated for
a better workout performance and adding
a little bit of protein prior to your
workout will help to reduce muscle
soreness so try this presentation shake
and the next snack is dressed up oatmeal
oat milk is a popular choice for long
runs or long cardio as it provides
energy throughout your workout by
gradually releasing sugar into your
blood stream
you can choose to top your oatmeal with
fresh fruits peanut butter whole nuts
egg or cocoa powder just like what I
have here if you like something more
substantial like me why not try egg on
toast this is my regular breakfast and
also mainly my pre-workout snack 1 or 2
whole wheat toast with one hunt a slice
egg is an excellent source of protein it
keeps you satisfied and it is much
easier to digest in comparison to meat
meat is something you should try to
avoid as your pre-workout snacks as it
takes much longer to digest and it will
weigh you down during your workout
session so try a on toast
instead now if you don't have the time
and you want a quick
which you can eat on the move try dried
fruits and nuts
you can pack it in a container and bring
it out with you the healthy sugar from
dried fruits will provide you with a
quick energy boost while nuts will keep
your insulin level from dropping during
your workout session nuts are high in
healthy fat which means they take longer
to digest so if you consume a little too
many you can start to feel sluggish so
remember to have it in moderation and a
small handful is more than enough
as your pre-workout snack another quick
pre-workout snack which I often make its
my peanut butter oatmeal energy bar you
can get the full recipe from my full
vegan meal plan video this energy bar
contains all natural ingredients needed
for an excellent workouts oatmeal peanut
butter and honey for workout endurance
and for a quick energy boost so you can
make this beforehand and this can be
stored in the fridge for up to a week so
try it out other easy and quick
pre-miracle snacks can include all kinds
of fruits cottage cheese with crackers
low sugar sports drink caffeine which is
going to boost your metabolism and to
improve performance endurance and many
different kinds of whole food which is
high in cups so let's move on to
post-workout meals and snacks your
post-workout meal is the first meal you
have after your workout session which is
also known as the anabolic phase having
the right post-workout meal will help
with increasing muscle mass to reduce
fatigue and muscle soreness and with
overall recovery to achieve this we want
to refill our body with high protein and
a little bit of carbs protein consists
of amino acids which build muscle and
help with recovering our muscle breaks
down during a workout and needs to be
rebuilt with protein for these reasons
we are encouraged to consume our
post-workout meals within 32
sixty minutes right after a workout
session this is when our body is most
ready to accept the carbs and protein
and to use these nutrients to reboot
restore and recover I like to schedule
my big meal right after a workout
session for instance I tend to work out
mid-morning and to have my lunch
straight after knowing that this is not
always possible for all of us I will be
sharing some examples of post-workout
snacks and meals that you can try out so
let's start with meals what I have here
is basic grilled chicken with veggies
your body is in recovery mode so you
need a nutrient-dense dish the lean
protein in the grilled chicken will fill
you up without feeling overly bloated
and the veggies are high in fiber and
they will keep you satisfied without
over eating the next meal is veggie
omelet what I have in here are broccolis
spinach carrots onions two eggs cooked
with a little bit of olive oil again
eggs are an easy source of protein they
are light on your body and they will
keep you satisfied and this is also a
great choice for vegetarians
another great post-workout meal is
salmon with sweet potato chips which is
my favorite because I love salmon and I
love sweet potatoes salmon is a great
source of protein with omega-3 and the
sweet potato chips is packed with
complex carbs which helps to restore
energy especially after an intense
workout if you are a vegan you can
always substitute the salmon or the
grilled chicken breast with beans or
even chickpeas so now let's move on to
some quick and light post-workout snacks
what I have here are tuna chunks and red
pepper hummus tuna is very low in
calories but high in protein 100 gram of
tuna only contains 99 calories and it
has 23 point five grams of protein
hummus is also low in calories and high
in protein and it is a great vegan
option too
feel your protein requirement so you can
either have tuna or hummus or both with
crackers or you can even make a sandwich
and pack it out with you so there is no
cooking required at all and this is
really convenient chocolate lovers this
is for you
recent research has shown that chocolate
milk is the latest craze in post-workout
snacks even over water and sports drink
this is because one cup of chocolate
milk has everything you need cups to
restore energy protein for muscle
recovery and water content to replace
lost fluid from exercising so chocolate
lovers after a workout is the perfect
time to indulge in a cup of hot
chocolate milk again smoothie it's also
a great post-workout snack
it's delicious feeling convenient and
helps to replenish lost fluid from
exercising I've added a little bit of
spinach into my smoothie you can watch
my reduce bloating 3 day detox plan
video to learn how to make a delicious
and healthy green smoothie the easiest
and most convenient way to refill your
body with protein is to drink protein
shakes each scoop of protein powder has
an average of 24 grams of protein and no
protein shakes are not just for men
you can choose to mix one scoop of
protein powder with water or with milk
for extra carbs and protein if you are a
man and you are much bigger in size then
go for 2 scoops a quick stop or
post-workout fix is to consume protein
bar just be aware of the sugar content
go for protein bars with 10 to 30 gram
of protein less than 10 grams of sugar
and with minimal amount of ingredients
you can't pronounce so this are just
some examples of post-workout meals and
snacks if you find that the portions are
too small you can always add a site of
vegetables rice couscous quinoa baked
potato vegetable soup and more adjust
the portion according to your personal
requirement most of these meals can be
prepped beforehand for convenience if
you are a vegan please visit this link
below for high-protein plant-based foods
to fulfill your protein needs if you
have never given much thought it regards
to your pre and post-workout snacks try
it out because they will make a
significant difference to your workout
performance and results as a basic
guideline remember to fill your body
with cost or energy and to refill your
body with protein for recovery the more
basic your foods are the better they
will be for your body as long as you aim
to consume whole food and real food you
will be on the right track to optimize
workout performance and results and
always remember to stay hydrated before
during and after your workout so carry a
bottle of water with you at all times
all the best for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
website do you follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
you
[Music]